great friend of the program he's been
with nfl network for
he was with the nfl network for so many
years in 2012 from
2012 and on no he was already out of
football at the time
that was week six weeks okay
um and what he has built himself is
quite a hell of a career post-playing
career
um also on american ninja warrior the
author that of
everyone can be a ninja find your inner
warrior and achieve your dreams now
available now and paperback
and now part of the beverly hills dog
show presented by purina that's on nbc
on sunday night at 80 sometime my friend
akbar baja miller how are you sir
i'm doing good rich you have a dog too
don't you oh i have two sir
okay i i figured that i have two
and they what kind of dogs do you have
uh we have two rescues
but they are purebreds my wife my wife
uh saw
a golden retriever about geez right
around this time
two years ago uh who was thrown in a
trash can believe it or not in boynton
park california
oh wow we went and got her uh and then
there was a white english golden
that was tied to a boat somewhere near
the nevada california border we
drove and got her and um
and akbar every single time we have a
dog in our household which is now
uh now 20 years running i get knocked
down a peg in terms of the most
important being in the house
i guess
my wife and i we got married um 2003 we
moved down here for nfl network we
rescued
uh hudson who was uh roaming the streets
of uh southern california here in los
angeles he was a mix
um we thought he was he had to be a mix
of a german shepherd and a lab
and a keita there was also he's a
beautiful dog he lived 15 years ago
let me call you out real quick because
this this is one of my
pet peeves no pun intended
when people start naming just right i
like
all my dogs akita and this and look they
didn't do a 23andme on dogs they don't i
don't think they do that
like so oh yes oh yes they do
are you kidding me akbar yes they do
and my wife my wife susie 23 and me
like we literally yes you could do this
are you serious yes yes
absolutely oh wow this is no longer a
petite there this is an interest
no say that again chris you could say it
i mean he's awkward i mean
look it seems like you should know that
before you host a
dog show excuse me no you know i'm not a
dna specialist okay
by the way how many how many how many
how many mixed breed rescues were at the
beverly hills dog show
presented by purina zero exactly
full blue tarsky well you know it's
crazy because at the
beverly hills dog show they have two new
breeze that the american kennel club
just allowed in the bar bay which is a
french dog in the uh dogo argentino so
correct
now by the way
a lot of people don't know but like
that's been kind of my side
passion is um uh our dogs
i train my own dogs um now i have knicks
breeds
so my dogs don't qualify to be in the
beverly hills uh there you go
dog show but that's just one of those
things i remember
early on my very first couple of years
at the nfl network i would go after i
finished doing the fantasy show
i would go train dogs my wife was like
what are you doing you spent all day
at the studio and then you go train
people's dogs and i would do it for like
50
just because to me it was a time to get
away i love spending the time with the
pets
i'd never advertised it people heard
about it and i've trained everything
from german shepherds
to pit bulls um never a mixed dog
actually believe it or not i've never
trained a mixtalk
uh but but anyways yeah so that's kind
of how when this popped up for me the
beverly hills dog show
i wanted to do more or less behind the
scenes of myself maria manunos
um we you know we do the behind the
scenes just kind of taking you
to like because there's a lot that goes
on which reminds me a little bit about
the nfl
and in professional sports and the the
preparation for these dogs and what they
have the owners and the trainers
um that they have to go through in order
to get the dogs ready from the
concentration drills
to all of the manicure and pedicures and
whatever it is that they do
uh for the grooming for the dogs it's
pretty intense
so uh it's a it's definitely gonna be a
great family show to watch
this weekend oh we'll be on that that's
for sure your big hit my household is
you know akbar because of the american
ninja warrior
i've told you that over and over and
over yeah yeah yeah well i'm looking to
hopefully to get back into filming uh
we've been all you know kind of put on
pause right now of course
given the the coronavirus so we're
hoping to get put back
on uh on the go here we'll see kind of
how things unfold is obviously a very
fluid thing
and but this is a great time we need to
talk about you know no sports and house
fortress kind of rolling out
i think this is a kind of a great way to
get a little bit of family and
family time in some sports in with the
it's a
different type of show but these are dog
ninja warriors so to speak i love it
i love it well let's put a pin in the
dog conversation for a moment and
and circle back one more time because i
love dogs as much as you do too here
um let's talk a little bit about the the
nfl story of the day
did you hear this about james harrison
akbar have you heard about this i
i heard the 75 000 that he was fined for
that big hit
and mike tomlin just gave him an
envelope like like on the streets like
yo here you go
uh clean that up kind of thing i i
i'm kind of baffled by that but i always
know that i knew
james harrison has this issue with uh
mike tomlin
because he and who's the other guy
antonio brown that he and they've kind
of partnered up and they've kind of been
buddy buddied and it looks like
from me just just and again i don't know
that locker room has not been in it
um and i'm not saying whether he's lying
or not i don't i don't know but
i do know that they partnered up him and
antonio on this smear campaign
against mike tomlin so uh it's odd that
it would come out at this time
um i don't i don't know why he would
give him 75 000
when james harrison is making i mean an
uber amount of money more
than than mike tomlin you know what i
mean well i mean just
let's just let's just throw it all out
there then but in your
five seasons of playing in the nfl and
and multiple seasons of covering it and
knowing as many
uh uh players as you do have you ever
heard
of something like that we're never an
envelope
to the player no no i mean i think
there's a lot of
there's a lot of stories out there about
the oakland raiders um
you know the bad boys and sports and bad
boys football
um and i've seen some crazy things when
i was with the raiders
um but that if that was going to happen
that would happen
under the myth and the mystique of the
oakland raiders
i just i don't know what coach is making
that kind of cheese to just go yo here's
75 wrecks
um for for for for that hit that you
know you're gonna get fined for
and so here you go i'm gonna pay your
bill for it i just i've never heard of
it yeah i i
and it's so out of character for tomlin
too you know right
i mean it just makes no sense that
tomlin's gonna be like okay great hit
and you know and and
days after the the the hit he's still so
intense and outraged by it he's gonna
find
uh a whole bunch of cash stick it an
envelope and hand it to james harrison
who hasn't said anything about it for 10
years i i i think what you have to do is
you kind of have to look at the
relationship
uh to be able to get a little bit more
uh behind this story just because you
put something out there especially right
now
i think the sports world we're starving
for stories and this is a great way
if you're gonna you know maybe engage in
a smear campaign or just to get your
name floating out there
you put a story out front like that um
but how do you verify something like
that
you know i mean what are you gonna go on
a paper chase you're to go look at 10
years i think after every seven years
don't they erase your bank statements i
don't know i don't even know
i don't think you go seven years more
than seven years and get your bank
records
so how do they even find that you know
what i mean doc bart baja b miller here
on the rich eisen show it there's one
thing that harrison did point out on
uh what is his instagram feed today
chris when he brings you
is that is that there there was um he
did get caught up in what the nfl
uh was uh doing at the time which was
mid-stream in the middle of the season
changing the way that they were
asking players like a point they added a
point of emphasis
mid-season which never happens that
never ever happens they usually
will add a point of emphasis in the uh
off season
or in the preseason if you want to be
late but very rare will they say we're
going to add a point of emphasis on
hitting somebody
in in the in in the game and
because as harrison points out the hit
on massaqua was not flagged
and it was you know fined later on which
is there is
that happens all the time in the nfl but
i remember that remember that it was
that hit it was the hit that dante
robinson blew up
desean jackson and brandon merriweather
and top rope on todd heap
so you know he is kind of right about
that
yeah nice for the wwe reference but yeah
i do remember that hit and i also
remember that time and that was a very
frustrating time too for players the
defense players just because it's like
you know a lot of that has to do with
muscle memory and now you're telling me
to change that
especially when you know those bang bang
plays and instincts
it's very hard to just say hey and then
we're gonna find you because you can't
you can't turn that off um that's that's
awkward that was weird
um but who knows i wonder where this
story goes i don't i don't know that it
goes farther
rich to be honest with you unless he can
show that he's got bank statement and
proof of that
75 000 in the envelope so
um let's just switch gears a little bit
here why do you think can i get
asked this question all the time why
isn't cam uh
in a camp right now why doesn't have a
job do you think
that that one is baffling to me um
because the truth is kim kam newton is
still a very very
talented quarterback and i would have to
imagine
that it has a lot to do with you know
personality
uh and how he fits into a team because
you know it's cool watching this last
dance thing and
it kind of takes you back to being in
the locker room and just the dynamic and
chemistry of players and when you have
moving pieces
you can still be talented and yet uh
when
especially i'm talking about with the
isaiah thomas magic johnson
olympic 92 olympics and just to hear
magic johnson joining them talking about
just the dynamics of a team
people forget about that isaiah wasn't a
bum
but you know he felt that they were
gonna he was gonna be disruptive to that
team and i think
there's concerns about cam newton being
disruptive to a team especially a team
that could go far but
um i just don't know where he would land
i look at
all of the different teams and i go
who's going to
but does cam newton it's a confusing
question because i cannot imagine
football without cam newton right for
the 2020 season that just doesn't that's
not realistic
i mean he's better than a lot of
quarterbacks out there
i agree with you i think maybe he's just
gonna wait until
somebody gets hurt or i i don't know or
hopefully you know whatever's going on
with the virus
can can be um
ease to the point where you know
uh therapeutics palliatives and whatever
uh uh
opens up society to be honest with you
i thought he was gonna end up with the
chargers i thought if anybody
could with um with the way the chargers
been struggling to get
you know fans in the seat you know cam
has got the looks
he's got the talent he's got that la
player swag it just seemed like it would
make sense he would be able to bring
you know seats in here he's got that
thing where people are going to want to
come see him
and i just thought it would make sense
um on so many different levels and when
i saw that the chart was growing in a
different direction that was kind of a
head scratcher for me well i mean i
think they yellowed with brady
didn't work and that was it they weren't
gonna go
yolo with somebody who might have um a
foot shoulder
or or what have you but to me i i
thought that they would
sorry well i'm allergic to this
conversation but i think you might end
up rich
i don't know somebody's got to get hurt
first somebody's got to get hurt
but but listen to what you're saying
that that's crazy
it is crazy somebody has to get hurt but
the reason
the reason why it's a job yeah the
reason why i brought up palliatives and
i brought up
therapeutics it's because somebody's got
although i got to tell you what man i
keep saying this
but they gave brady uh um
a physical they apparently todd gurley
how to get a physical i mean
physicals could be could be gotten
through uh
reputable physicians that everyone can
agree on
is is good enough cam is also like if
you want if somebody wants to hire him
you can send a plane for him
right and then he can show up somewhere
hopefully covet 19 free and get this
physical
it's really weird man you know what you
you know where you should go real talk
i'm just thinking about this
i know i went on and people got crazy
and said i can't believe and then it
happened
uh when the cleveland browns when got
case keenum i called that
maybe two three weeks prior to and i
said they're gonna go after case keenum
uh because it makes sense and i don't
know the financials i'm just kind of off
the top this is more of an emotional
thing
but because of the different pieces that
they have over there in cleveland
i think you could make something make a
case that i i'm still not a believer
in in baker mayfield i think he's a guy
that's trying to manufacture leadership
um i'm not saying that he's not talented
but there's there's just a couple of
missing key pieces that
he's missing i think cam newton would be
a better fit for the cleveland browns
that would be amazing i mean if 2020 if
2020 only
could have that added to it too i just
don't know how that would happen though
yeah yeah that would be amazing wow
i can't even ima i mean cam the odell
and cam the jarvis and
what big but hey look man this is the
truth though baker this is his
evaluation season they have
they have set up i've said this before
i'll say it with you here on the phone
um that that they have set up the
ability to evaluate baker in a way i
wish the jets had set up
themselves to evaluate sam darnold
unless they just feel that sam darnold's
always been
already been appropriately evaluated and
it doesn't really matter that they are
going to just
keep him past year four year five pick
up his option figure out what to do then
but this is truly um a baker mayfield
evaluation year would you say
yeah no it is i thought last year was an
evaluation but then it
turned into uh excuses well this that
and the other and
you know and to me it was kind of clear
and i think i saw it early
when and again you know that
manufactured leadership i'm just going
to try to fake it and call
you know teammates out at the beginning
of this at the beginning during the off
season
and then i'm trying to talk my way
through this and i'm trying to fake it
till i make it kind of thing
and and then it just kind of went south
and there was so much hype and again
that's a lot to carry on there's a lot
of hype but then
there's the stash gate and uh this and
all this other stuff and i'm like this
dude
he's not serious he's he's more or less
wanting to be famous he
and especially to this can when you're
impressionable like that and you get
odell beckham in your
in your locker room he's got that cool
factory you want to be like him i saw a
lot of
little copycat things i'm picking up on
you know as a player you can pick up on
ll he wants to be like him oh he's
acting like that
oh he thinks i'm like no dude you're the
quarterback you got to be focused on
ball
you got to be focused on leading that
team with your play
first before you start trying to dress
and talk like
you know a quote-unquote leader and um
yeah so anyways yeah
that is that's pretty much it um a
couple more minutes left with akbar baja
biamilla here on the rich eisen show
okay so
set the table for me sunday night eight
eastern time i'm settling in
and and and what am i going to get i'm
going to get dogs i'm going to get a
looking at all these wonderful beautiful
creatures on
on the planet and somebody gets crowned
the winner yes am i going to get crowned
that we we we're bringing back the
havanese bono the havanese dog who won
last year and he's obviously the
favorite bono's
the favorite to win it again okay but
there's some new dogs who are coming
into the competition you'll have your
sporting group you're gonna have your
working group
uh those are the pretty dogs that kind
of pants around and
you know they got that little strut but
the beverly hills dog show the 2021 i
think it's going to be a real good one
you're going to see some athleticism
you're going to see the pageantry
uh but yeah there you go it's on nbc
it's uh
it's what we have it's it's a it's a
great sporting event
i can't wait that's gonna be a lot of
fun man and if one of them goes potty on
the floor we see you going
holding and going up going up with an
envelope go up with an envelope to fix
this thing
my good friend beau derek bo and i have
become really good friends over the
years
um where she she has her own shampoo
line and she provides me with all the
shampoo for my dog
it's amazing uh product by the way but
uh there are a whole bunch of
celebrities they'll be out there to
clean up the poop not me i sit back
mario lopez you know uh so
messiah luke might flip in at football
over there if you saw that so i got to
be honest with you akbar i've learned
more and more about you
every single time you and i talk so i
did not know you and bo derek go way
back
i just didn't know that well we don't go
way back but i mean
for the last three years we've been at
the beverly hills dog show
i guess three years is way back but okay
okay there's that and i had no idea that
when uh you would be leaving nfl network
after all those years you would be going
home to
to to train the dog train i i had no
idea
yeah and then you were so bad yeah if
you ever have uh problems with your dogs
you know
i could uh and now that i know you have
pure breeds i can
and not to mention i mean you you're
very familiar with 901
90210 do i get that right well we are we
are very
look i don't want to i don't want i
don't want a picture painted of me here
that i've
we have rescue dogs and my wife just saw
this golden and it would just happen to
be she thought it was we didn't know
that it was a pure bread
it looked like you're bread man rich
first off your nickname is rich because
obviously you're rich
the dog was right near angel stadium so
let's let's let's
that's where the dog was and we went and
drove to go get her and then the one
that we drove was as far from there
wasn't a hill there wasn't a beverly
there wasn't
doe derek there wasn't anything where we
picked up the white english gold and
i'll tell you that
all right nothing close to a perfect 10
where i went where we drove and picked
up that white english dog thank you
chris thank you very much
thank you okay i'm going to let you
slide on that i won't give you this one
he's such he's such an excellent trainer
uh chris now i know why maurice jones
drew started using the proper bathroom
at work
is that wrong wow was that wrong wow was
that resemblance
this conversation is officially off the
rails
hey you know what that was great that
was a great tactic right there to get it
off of you being rich
and and and only selecting straight dogs
that are purebred
and here i thought the worst shortening
of my name was dick
and now it's now we've got something
else here hey now hey now
we are officially off the real zak bar
but look man oh no it's all good uh i'm
looking forward to you
seeing you on i just love watching you
you look at you on a
network television on on sunday night
eight eight eastern on nbc the beverly
hills dog show
presented by purina i look forward to it
brother all right thanks a lot
always stay in touch let's uh let's stay
in touch okay now
take care that's akbar baja biamilla at
akbar understore
underscore baja which is the it's the
silent g everybody silent g
g-b-a-j-a on both twitter and instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here